CHARLIE SAWYER:
I'm Charlie Sawyer.
I work here in the Cambridge
office on gTech, specifically,
Google Flight Search.
And it's my great
pleasure-- have a seat, Ron.
RON LEVY: I wanted to say
thank you all for coming.
CHARLIE SAWYER: I
first became acquainted
with Ron in 1970, when I
was researching a book that
became a biography of
B.B. King after a 10- year
search and rejection
by 53 publishers.
And it was published
by Doubleday.
Now at that same time, Ron
was working on a book himself.
I don't know if he
was really fully aware
that he was working on a book.
And he was doing
research, we might say.
And it took another, what, 30?
40 years of research--
RON LEVY: But who's counting?
CHARLIE SAWYER: --to
realize this book,
which is our topic today,
"Tales of a Road Dog."
And the way we've
decided to structure
this is I'm going to
start with the question
I think everybody
will have in mind.
Then Ron will give us a tour of
the content of the book, which
is an ebook, as well as
the book you've seen here.
So I'll start with
this question, Ron.
How does a 19-year-old
white kid from Brookline
become B.B. King's organ player?
How does that happen?
RON LEVY: OK.
Well, first of all-- I'll sit
here-- I was 18, actually.
And actually my father and B.B.
belonged to the same squash
club, the Boston
Athletic Association.
And they used to-- they would
swap partners playing squash.
CHARLIE SAWYER: You're joking.
RON LEVY: Yes, I am.
CHARLIE SAWYER: All right.
RON LEVY: OK.
CHARLIE SAWYER: That's
not the B.B. I know.
RON LEVY: Yeah, I figured you
didn't know that about B.B.
CHARLIE SAWYER: No, I didn't.
RON LEVY: He was
excellent at squash.
He couldn't beat my dad, though.
B.B. had him over a [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLIE SAWYER:
What's the real story?
RON LEVY: OK.
So before I played with
B.B., I was-- actually,
I had first met B.B.
When I was about 15.
And I went to Roxbury
one Saturday night
to this place called
Louie's Lounge.
And I was underage, and I
stood out there in the alleyway
and listened to the
music through the door.
OK.
So fast forward a
couple of years.
The same year, I had a
little band in high school.
And we ended-- Don Long, the
famous promoter here in Boston
who does many concerts and
owned The Paradise and what not.
He was going to
Harvard at the time,
and he was our manager
of my high school band.
And if you ask me
the name of the band,
we changed the name of the band
pretty much every other week.
So we had 50 different names
over the course of a couple
years.
But anyway, he got us
these gigs backing up
Big Mama Thornton
and John Lee Hooker.
And we became friends
with Muddy Waters Band
and Howling Wolf's
band at the Club 47,
and Luther Johnson, who played
with Muddy-- not the Luther
Johnson Guitar Junior, but the
Georgia boy Luther Johnson.
So we started to get into
this whole mix of playing
with these Bo Diddley
and Chuck Berry.
Whenever they would come to
town, we would play with them.
And then Albert King
was playing in Boston
and on Lennie's on the Pike.
And Lenny Sokolov, he just
passed away last week.
Well, anyway, we were opening
up the show for Albert.
And we finished our set,
and it was very nice crowd,
and they thought we were
great, for little kids playing.
And we just heard this ruckus
backstage and all this yelling
and furniture being moved
through the air against walls.
And turns out Albert
fired his band on the spot
and hired us to back him up.
Now he took my
drummer and myself
out on the road with him.
And that's a whole long story
that's funny in the book
that you'll hear about.
But after I had been with Albert
for about a year and a half--
and Albert was reputed to
be one of the hardest people
to work with-- I mean, it
was-- if you could survive
the wrath of Albert, you could
survive anything, I mean,
it was-- it was like
the blues Taliban.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Is it true that
he had a Thompson submachine
gun?
RON LEVY: Yes, he did.
Many weapons.
But I only saw him
pull that out one time.
And he never played with
his guns or showed them off.
He was very responsibility.
He was actually a deputy
Sheriff in Lovejoy, Illinois.
But after playing on
shows with Albert King
and doing double bills with
B.B. King and Albert King,
they started to take-- B.B.
King's band, Sonny Freeman,
the longtime bandleader
and drummer--
took notice of
Albert's little group.
And for some reason,
they pointed at me,
and when the slot opened
up, I got a call from Sonny.
Actually he called
my mother's house,
because I didn't have
my own phone then.
And the rest is in the book.
CHARLIE SAWYER:
So you were riding
with the Kings, both of them.
RON LEVY: Right.
And my first night with B.B.,
nobody welcomed me to the band.
There was no set list,
there was no instruction,
it was just, put
these clothes on,
get up there play your
butt off, and good luck.
And that was it.
Nobody-- we'll get into the
specifics of that a little bit
later.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Why don't you
give us a tour of the book now?
RON LEVY: OK.
Now this book here
is kind of my own--
I'd never seen anyone else do
this-- and I came up with this.
This is my website
here, as you can see.
I have to look here so
I know what I'm doing.
I think you can see it there.
And see where it says,
come for a test drive
underneath the
picture of the book?
That takes you to another
page where it's got reviews,
it's got Table of Contents,
Various Artists, Personalities
and Subjects, Open Letter
from the Author-- me.
And then it's got short
excerpts from the book.
So you kind of go for a
test drive on this, OK?
So we're going to open it up.
We're gonna go to
the real book now.
And as you can see, we've
got a Table of Contents here.
And wasn't there a question
you wanted to ask me?
We could go to the book.
Anyway, what we'll do is we'll
start-- since Charlie's here
we'll do the B.B. King
Chronicles, Chapter 3.
So how I designed this
was to have the text
and then have pictures
right next to it,
just like a magazine.
And by being online I
was able to have, like,
3,000 pictures on
the web book, where
there's no way I could
have been able to do
that if it was a print book.
And then you'll notice,
you'll see it says Meter Maid.
It's like red highlight there.
And then you look
a little further.
And so this has really a
wealth of a lot of pictures.
Here's a picture of B.B.
King with Sid Seidenberg, who
was B.B.'s manager,
very-- brought
blues to the whole world.
And you'll see a
poster next to it
that B.B. Headlined
over Jimi Hendrix.
And it was one of
Hendrix's last shows
in America, or anywhere
for that matter.
Sorry, Jimi.
Here's a picture
of B.B.'s old bus.
CHARLIE SAWYER: That
picture of Ed Sullivan,
I took that picture.
RON LEVY: There
was a picture of--
CHARLIE SAWYER: There's
one at the High Chaparral,
but it's farther down, probably.
But the picture of--
RON LEVY: The picture
that's in the print book.
It's like-- so is that good?
Does anybody have any
questions about this?
AUDIENCE: How long did it take
you to put the book together?
RON LEVY: Well, it came
in different stages.
The production of this on the
web book took about almost
a year.
And what I did, too--
I didn't work on it
for a full year just in a
row, because what I want to do
is work on-- just dedicate
myself to it like for two
or three, four months, and
then walk away from it.
And I didn't even think about
it, I didn't like peek at it.
I didn't do anything.
And I wanted to just come
back like maybe a month
later, six to eight weeks later,
and just look at it fresh.
Because I wanted everything
to get out of my mind so
I'd be able to look at it
how someone who had never
seen it before would look at it.
And how I got this--how
this came about,
I did not plan this
from the beginning.
What happened was, when
I wrote my first draft,
I sent emails to
various friends of mine
that were there, at whatever
particular chapter I was in,
to verify my facts and to
see, maybe I forgot something,
or, you know, I would
tell them, read this.
Did I get everything?
What was so-and-so's name?
How do you spell this?
And was that the town?
I had questions myself.
And most people were
just flabbergasted
about how much I remembered.
They just-- they were
going, oh my god.
Actually, one of my
drummers said to me,
he said, you know,
Lev, he goes, I
read the chapter
about you and me.
And he says, man, I was
going to take a shower
and get dressed and go to
work and come pick you up.
Because I had brought
the flavor of it.
He goes, man, you put
me back like 10 years.
I thought it was like today
that you were writing about.
So it was a lot of fun and a lot
of the exchange on that regard.
But what happened was, when I
sent the emails to everybody,
then I started adding
pictures to it.
Then I started adding
links to YouTube
and I started making
YouTube links myself.
And it just kind of
morphed into this web book.
And that's how it was.
Another thing that was
particularly unbelievable
about the production of
it was that every time I
wrote about somebody
or had their picture,
even if I hadn't spoken
with that person for 15,
20, sometimes 30 years,
within two or three days
afterwards I would hear
from somebody that we
knew in common, or I
would hear from them.
It was unbelievable.
It was like a psychic ESP
thing going on, I mean,
cross country.
And very much so of people
that had passed away.
I could really
feel them with me.
And I could really
transport myself
back to whatever time
it was, and actually
just completely recall exact
conversations that we had.
It freaked me out, to
be honest with you.
I couldn't believe it.
And it just kept on happening
over and over and over again.
And at one point--
Charlie remembers Cato,
you gave me a beautiful
picture of him--
and he and I had this adventure
that was just unbelievable.
And it took me about two weeks
to write about this adventure.
And I finally crafted
it and came with it,
and I started to
read it to my wife,
and I couldn't get through it.
I started choking up.
And I had to stop,
because otherwise I
would have started crying.
And she came over to me and
she said, honey, are you OK?
And I just said, you know, the
last two weeks it's like Cato
and I were together.
So much, we were like sitting
next to each other riding
down the highway.
And it's done now.
I'm not going to see him again.
I'm not gonna share
the experience again.
Little did I know the 400
times I had to reread my drafts
and do the editing
and everything,
that I would
experience it again.
CHARLIE SAWYER: So
Cato started as B.B.'s
bus driver and mechanic.
RON LEVY: When I
was born, in 1951.
And Cato was the city boy
because he grew up in Memphis
and went to college
and was on a train.
He worked on the trains, he was
a union member of the trains.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Pullmans.
RON LEVY: And B.B. was
the country boy that came.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And Cato's
brother, [? Shinny ?] Walker
was the bass player
in that band.
RON LEVY: That's right,
at the beginning.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And Cato's
wife Polly became B.B.'s--
RON LEVY: Road manager.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Road manager.
RON LEVY: She had the biggest
map of the United States
I've ever seen in my life.
It was like almost
as big as this.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And
their son, Cato III,
became B.B.'s horn player.
RON LEVY: Right, years later.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Years
and years later.
And both Cato the elder
and Polly worked for B.B.
Until the day they died.
RON LEVY: Exactly.
And even when old man Cato,
as we used to call him--
we also used to
call him Iron Jaws
because he could talk
more than anybody
that anybody had ever known.
So we called him-- his
nickname was Iron Jaws.
And I wrote in the book, he
could talk the bark off a tree.
I mean, he could stand next to
a street lamp for five minutes
and carry on a conversation.
And it was like, Cato,
stop, it's like--
So we're going to go
with some questions here?
CHARLIE SAWYER: Yes,
come back, sit down.
RON LEVY: We'll have
some more music, too.
CHARLIE SAWYER: How
fast was the pace?
How many gigs did you
do in a typical year?
RON LEVY: All right.
Well, I've remarked that
we covered more miles
back then than UPS does today.
There was one time--
to just give you
an idea of what
our schedule was--
one time we did a television
show in New York City,
flew from La Guardia to
Chicago, played at a festival
maybe about an hour outside of
Chicago, went back to O'Hare,
and then flew to LAX.
And we did a breakfast show
in South Central Los Angeles
that night, like 2 o'clock,
3 o'clock in the morning.
That was an extreme day.
There were other times
when we played in Vegas,
and we played at various
places like the Hilton,
the Flamingo, Caesar's Palace,
that often we'd fly-- you know,
those gigs were usually like 10
o'clock at night to 4 o'clock
in the morning.
And there was-- there
was another band.
We would always alternate.
And then the other
bands, you're asking,
would be like Little Richard
or Erroll Garner or Duke
Ellington, or they
would run the gamut.
It was just unbelievable.
And this was in the
lounge for the most part.
But a lot of times
when we did those Vegas
gigs, we would fly to LA in
the afternoon and play, like,
"Midnight Special"
or "Sanford and Son"
or one of those other TV shows.
And then we'd fly back to Vegas
and play like a regular night.
CHARLIE SAWYER:
Give us a number.
How many gigs a year?
RON LEVY: I Easily 300 plus.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Did
you get a vacation?
RON LEVY: No.
Our vacation were our days off.
CHARLIE SAWYER: So you did
have a day off now and then.
RON LEVY: Yeah.
If it was like a death in the
family or something like that,
you could take a personal day.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And
what if you got sick?
RON LEVY: That was
against the rules.
CHARLIE SAWYER: If
you could walk--
RON LEVY: I remember there was--
when I first joined the band,
we played this festival.
And Duke Ellington
was playing piano,
Oscar Peterson was playing
piano, Ray Charles and Dave
Brubeck-- and I saw
this on the schedule.
We were in the hotel, and
I was like 18 years old.
I called up Sonny and I said,
Sonny, I got a stomachache.
I don't think I
can make this gig.
And he was going, like,
well Ron, you gotta make it.
Do you need to go
to the hospital?
And I said, well, no.
I just I don't feel good.
No way I can-- really
I was just nervous.
Because I faked
it the whole time.
And with these guys,
they don't fake it.
Duke Ellington and everybody,
they don't fake it at all.
And so finally, he kept on
asking me all these questions,
and then I just said--
finally it came out,
I forget how it came out, that
I was nervous to be in front.
And he just started laughing,
and he was very big brother-ish
to me, and very kindly to me.
And he says, hey, Ron, you
know, we all feel like that.
Your job is not to
be Duke Ellington
or Oscar Peterson
or Dave Brubeck.
Your job is to be Ron Levy,
B.B. King's piano player.
Just worry about doing that
job and you'll be fine.
And that was like
the best advice.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And what
about if B.B. got sick?
Did B.B. ever get sick?
Did B.B. ever cancel a date?
RON LEVY: No, you
couldn't get sick, man.
Another time we were Japan,
and I woke up one morning,
and I got up from the bed
and went the bathroom.
And I had all these red
spots all over my face.
I couldn't believe it,
as bright as this shirt.
And it was like some kind
of chicken pox or something
like this.
It was a Sunday.
And so I called Leroy, the
manager, and the doctor
wasn't there at the Hilton.
So they sent me to some
doctor in Japan, in Tokyo.
And the driver, all
he had was a piece
of paper written in Japanese
to where I was supposed to go.
And he just dropped
me off on this corner.
And it was like, I
couldn't read anything.
Everything was in Japanese.
I didn't know where
to go, I don't
know how to get
another cab, whatever.
And he started driving away,
and I just ran down the street
and chased after-- he
was stopped at a light.
I said, man, I'm going
back to the hotel.
Hilton, Hilton, Hilton.
That was it.
And then Old Man Cato told
me-- he knew somebody,
and they told me
to drink some tea.
So I drank some tea, and somehow
I felt better after that.
My fever came down and
I wasn't all flushed.
I wasn't all red and all that.
But you couldn't get sick.
I mean, it was just not allowed.
CHARLIE SAWYER: So
you're playing 300
plus out of 365 days a year.
And you did that
with no vacation.
for seven years,
and you lived to tell about it.
How did you do that?
RON LEVY: Well, I'm
very blessed and lucky.
There's lot of times I
wouldn't have made it.
And there were times since I
wouldn't have made it either.
CHARLIE SAWYER: You
were a lot younger then.
RON LEVY: I was a lot younger.
And I don't really
have the desire
to do something like that again.
It was a lot more
fun when you're
in your teens and your 20s
than it is now, 40 years later.
CHARLIE SAWYER: There's one
story about the trailer, when
you had an extra
day in the trailer
that you left at the hotel.
RON LEVY: OK.
Now that's when I
was with Albert King.
You want me to read that?
CHARLIE SAWYER: You can.
Go ahead.
RON LEVY: This is when
I was with Albert.
And Albert was a very
demanding person.
Albert, for instance--
you'll see in this chapter,
too-- he would fire guys like
in the middle of Nebraska
if they didn't respect
him the right way.
OK, here we go.
Well, we had this
wonderful gig--
I'll set it up for
you--at the Fillmore West.
And all these--
we were so tired.
We had driven from St. Louis all
the way out to San Francisco.
And we wanted to
just do our show.
But then all these guys came
like Santana, and this Garcia
guy from Grateful Dead,
and all these other people.
And they kept jamming
and wanted to jam.
And we were like, oh man, we
just want to finish our show
and go home.
And every time it seemed
like one guy would go away,
there would be
another guy come out.
And the thing about
it was, in the band,
we hated that, because we
wanted to do our show that
was rehearsed and prepared,
and we knew what we were going.
And to throw in these wild
cards kind of just ruined it.
And they tried to
play against Albert,
and that was ridiculous.
I mean, it was just
like a Little Leaguer
going up against John Lester.
It didn't make sense.
So anyway, we had a long
night and we finally--
this is when we wake
up next morning.
"After a good night's
rest, we woke up
to one of those beautiful
California dreamy,
sunny days that
made it so famous,
drawing folks from
all over the world
to the scenic Bay Area for
the past few hundred years
now and always will.
That and Rice-A-Roni, of course.
"We stayed at a very nice,
clean, respectable motel
on Van Ness
Boulevard pretty much
in the heart of San Francisco.
From the second-story deck,
sipping motel room coffee,
admiring the shiny
golden state, we also
noticed, to our combined
pleasant surprise,
that the Imperial,
Albert's car, was absent.
Albert was up and gone.
We were really free.
"Such a beautiful city.
What to do?
Go to one of San Francisco's
wonderful museums,
visit their gorgeous
library, picnic in the park
by the Golden Gate Bridge, take
a guided tour of all the sites,
drive around and admire San
Francisco's fine architecture,
ride a cable car, explore
Chinatown, the waterfront,
a ballgame, visit
Alcatraz, maybe?
Nah, I don't think so.
We were looking for
some action, also known
as trouble, as
young man often do.
We conspired to chain and
lock the equipment trailer
to one of the wooden
posts holding up
the deck we were perched
on, take the freed wagon,
and head down to the
Fillmore district.
And we planned to meet
up with some hippies
and see what the
counterculture had
to offer the stars
of last night's show.
"I don't exactly
remember what we did
or who we met down
there, as it was later
obscured by events
beyond our control.
But after a few hours
or so of seeking
to fulfill our aimless and
restless desires in vain,
we figured it would be best
to head back and chill out
at the motel before Albert
returned from his own forays.
"As we pulled into
the motel's carport,
we all turned white,
me even whiter,
at the site of Albert's towering
over several of San Francisco's
finest, also surrounded
by four or five
black and white red-domed
police cruisers.
One Oh, wow, man.
At first confused
and instantly jolted
with a soaring spike
of adrenaline rush,
screaming all together
now, 'Oh, shit!
The trailer's gone!'
"Our first basic instinct
was to make a break for it
and race back to St.
Louis towards survival.
But Albert saw us first and
bellowed, 'There they are!
Come on here!' and waved us in.
Maybe we would experience
Alcatraz for real after all.
It seemed a far better
fate at the time
than the impending wrath of Mr.
King we all justly anticipated.
I don't ever remember wanting
to lock myself in the car
before or since, but
I certainly did then."
And so to finish up the story--
CHARLIE SAWYER: How did
they get the trailer?
It was chained.
RON LEVY: They sawed the post.
CHARLIE SAWYER: The post holding
up the rest of the hotel.
RON LEVY: Well, OK.
I'll finish-- let me
jump ahead a little bit.
"We had all lost everything
we had and needed, as it were,
and all suffered equally.
As it turned out, there
had been a recent rash
of such incidents
in the Bay Area
that the San Francisco
detectives were already
forelorn to talk about.
None of us were to
blame, but much thanks
to the ingenuity of the brazen
banditos who had sawed out
a four-inch-wide section through
the wooden post which held up
the upper walkway,
slid the chain
through in broad
daylight, no less,
and taken our trailer,
thus proving we
had taken the normal
responsible precaution
by chaining the trailer."
CHARLIE SAWYER: So you lost
your instruments, your clothes,
and your Hammond.
RON LEVY: "Albert was visibly
upset but totally comical,
in a normal but stern,
official-like voice
informed us the police,
his distant west coast
cousins of law
enforcement, needed
us to answer a few questions.
Everything proceeded
in relatively calm,
professional order despite our
shared internal heart-pounding
and nerve-numbing
vibrating state we were.
It was, I'm telling you--
we were so scared of him.
"Times, names, places
were formally recorded,
as well as the
trailer's contents.
One Hammond B-3 organ bench,
Leslie 147 tone cabinet
and cable box, one Fender jazz
bass guitar Sunburst, one set
of Blue Sparkle Rogers drums
with cymbals, one acoustic bass
amp, one acoustic guitar amp,
four suitcases of clothes,
and a couple of trunks
belonging to Mr. King.
One tool box and two Gibson
Flying V electric guitars.
Albert's Lucy had
been kidnapped along
with her identical twin sister."
CHARLIE SAWYER:
Did you ever get it
back, the contents
of the trailer?
RON LEVY: My footnote.
The trailer was discovered
some two or three years later
in a warehouse full
of other stolen items
as well which had
caught fire down
in some industrial
area of Frisco.
All of our contents
remained intact.
The trailer was never opened
until police examined it
and matched the items
with our filed complaint.
This was before computers,
mind you, long ago.
The Frisco police
department said
Albert called my mother to
inform her of the recovery.
Her/my phone number was listed
on the original police report.
Albert was gracious enough
to pay for the shipping
and crating back
to Brookline, Mass.
CHARLIE SAWYER: So, Ron,
while you're up there,
there's one-- one of the
best stories you tell,
which speaks to the
whole question of race.
And that's the episode
onstage with Nina Simone.
RON LEVY: You know, that
was one stupid episode.
And I have to say
that, you know,
you said that about how
was I treated in the band,
being the only Jewish guy?
But they did
whatever I said when
we went to Israel, trust me.
You know, we were
all like brothers.
And some of us, like Little
Joe from Chicago on trombone,
he and I are in
constant contact today.
And we were best friends.
We were like 17
and 18 years old.
And we're like very
much close, very close.
And a lot of the
guys in the band,
after I left B.B. and I
became a record producer
and traveled around the country,
I hired a lot of those guys
to play in my sessions.
And we made some great
records together.
But this actually--
OK, this was in 1972.
Down in New Orleans in 1972,
we played the New Orleans Jazz
and Heritage Festival.
It was a glorious day.
Quint Davis and Allison
Miner-- blessed memory--
both good friends, were
perfect hosts as well as
the main original organizers
of this wonderful longstanding
annual event.
Willy T, Bo Dallas,
and The Wild Magnolias
opened the show
with us to follow.
WIlly T was a dear
friend of mine,
and his brother played
alto saxophone with B.B.,
and there's a
bunch of adventures
that we had in New Orleans, too.
But to quote Dan
Morgenstern and Paul Lynch
from the "Downbeat"
article that summer:
"B.B. Felt like playing, and
his guitar work was phenomenal.
Lucille was talking
on his records,
King often backed by
indifferent studio groups.
If you really want
to hear him, hear
him live with his own band,
creating that unique rapport
with his audience.
In B.B.'s nine-piece band
there is one white musician,
pianist Ron Levy.
And therefore hangs a tale."
That's how I got
"Tales of a Road Dog."
"At the point in the set where
B.B. introduces all the side
men, also doing a rap
with the audience,
the music slows down to a vamp.
While everyone's attention
was focused on B.B.,
Nina Simone emerged stage
left with Don Pullen in tow.
I happened to see them
and kept watching.
"Next, Ms. Simone tapped
Ron Levy's shoulder
and motioned him away
from the keyboard.
She sat down on the piano
bench, pulling along
with somewhat unwilling
Pullen and began
to play, demonstrating
a blues vamp.
She then got up and
indicated for Pullen to stay
and left the stage.
"Levy soon reappeared
looking a bit bewildered.
And now the rap was
ending and the next number
was about to begin.
Missing the customary intro,
B.B. peeped at the piano
from the corner of his eye.
Levy finally grasped
Pullen's shoulder
and regained his rightful place.
"Inquiring later as to
what this was all about,
my worst suspicions
were confirmed.
Ms. Simone, feeling that a soul
brother should be at the piano,
had instigated the whole thing.
Aside from a total lack
of professionalism,
this incident was a disgraceful
display of prejudice
in action, wholly out place at a
jazz festival, the sole jarring
note of the entire four days."
So that was from
"Downbeat" magazine.
So now this is my commentary.
"As it turned out, I got
fined $50 for this incident.
When Miss Nina tapped me
on the shoulder initially,
I figured she and
B.B. had arranged
this as a jam-type collaboration
as a special event,
as was very common, until
she told me point blank,
"You shouldn't be
up here playing
the blues with B.B. King, you
white honky peckerwood son
of a bitch.
Go back home where you belong."
What a lovely lady.
Too bad she was so ugly, too.
Love hearing her
version of "Please
Don't Let Me Be Misunderstood."
I didn't.
My feelings weren't hurt at all.
I just figured she was
a crazy, bitter lady.
However, I had already
gotten up for her
as a professional courtesy
and was kind of stuck
in a no white man's
zone for a moment.
Old Man Cato came right up to me
and said, "What you doin', boy?
Get on back up there.
You done lost your mind?
Go back to your spot.
Damn, boy."
So I did.
Now this time, Don Pullen
an excellent pianist
who later played with Charles
Mingus, was at the piano.
I politely took over.
He was cool and as
befuddled as I was.
We ended up hanging out and
laughing about it all later.
He confirmed my suspicions,
and we remained casual friends
for years.
Back in our trailer
dressing room after our set,
B.B. cleared the room
and read me the riot act.
Oh boy, what a day.
In rather coarse
language he asked me
what the hell I
was thinking about.
I brilliantly
responded, I don't know.
He further scolded me some more,
then told him I had figured he
and Miss Simone had
planned it together,
but without her
comments, of course.
I left that out.
He then asked me, did I tell
you anything about this?
And I responded, B,
I'm not privy to all
your plans or decisions.
I'm just a side man.
B.B.: Well, if you want to
remain a side man in my band,
you best only get up
when I tell you to
and nobody else, understand?
It's going to cost you $50
to teach you a lesson, son.
Don't ever do that again, OK?
I learned my lesson and
never shared with him
what she'd said.
Then, interestingly enough,
when the "Downbeat" article
appeared a month or two
later, after B.B. read it,
he slipped me back the $50
and took me record shopping.
I had pretty much forgotten
all about this episode
until-- bla bla bla bla bla.
The lady was doing a
biography of Nina Simone
and she reminded-- I
completely forgot about it.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Wonderful.
I have a couple of kind of
technical questions, musician's
questions.
Now B.B. didn't play
from a set list.
RON LEVY: No.
Never.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And he was--
RON LEVY: Not back then.
After I left, towards the end,
the last year I was with him,
we changed the whole band,
then we went to a show.
And that's kind of when I left.
CHARLIE SAWYER: He was known
for his reading audiences
and knowing just how to
navigate through his repertoire.
How did you know what to play,
when he would capriciously
decide--
RON LEVY: It was
our job to know.
CHARLIE SAWYER:
Was it telepathy?
Was there a signal?
RON LEVY: Well, you
know, when I learned
how to play piano when I was
a kid, I saw Ray Charles.
The next day I brought
the radio from the kitchen
into our parlor.
And I put on the
radio and I just
started going like
this with my finger,
trying to catch
whatever notes I could
from the songs on the radio,
from WILD at the time.
And so I don't know,
maybe it was just a gift.
If I hear a certain tone,
I can go right to the piano
and hit it.
But a lot of it
took a lot of ESP.
You just had to know B. and
how he would read the audience.
You had to learn
and just sense what
he was going to do, and
then learn from him,
and say, OK, I bet
he's going to do this.
When we would do a show we
did a couple songs to open up
before he came on,
warm up the crowd.
But as soon as he hit the
stage, there was no count.
Personally, he never
counted off any songs.
He never went one, two, this
is in the key of B flat.
No, none of that.
It was just boom!
And you just had to know.
And we always started out with
"Every Day I Have the Blues,"
which was in B flat.
But even that, there was
never a count up to that.
Sonny would hit
the drums, go whap!
And the song would just
go, whap! [HUMS NOTES]
CHARLIE SAWYER:
And meanwhile B.B.
would be [INAUDIBLE]
on his guitar--
RON LEVY: And you
just had to know
what tempo it was going to be.
That we knew.
We knew that was
going to be B flat
and it was going
to be very fast.
Then we would break into
"How Blue Can You Get",
and the key is dog, as we
used to call it, which is D.
And you say "dog" because, you
know, singing over a crowd, D,
you don't know if someone's
saying B or G or C or whatever.
You just go, dog.
But then after that, it was
all up to whatever B.B. did.
And sometimes he would
play half of a song
and in the middle of a song
he just wouldn't feel it
or he didn't like it,
and he would just, zap!
And go to another
key, and just go
to a completely different song.
And you had to be
there and just know.
CHARLIE SAWYER: So I've seen
many times, he'd start to sing.
And he'd be uncomfortable
with the key.
And he'd want to modulate
the key half a step
or a whole step.
And it seemed like magic.
All of a sudden the band
would play two or three
chords and the key would change.
How was that cued?
RON LEVY: It wasn't.
We just had to know.
It was human.
Not like a computer, where
you have to program everything
perfectly.
This was human beings.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Don't
badmouth computers.
Don't badmouth computers either.
RON LEVY: This was before them.
That's how we did it back then.
We didn't have all these tools.
But now, like when we did
the "Cook County Jail" album,
the piano that I played
at was a prison piano.
They didn't bring in a special
piano for the recording
session.
It was the one that was
in the rec hall there.
And it probably
hadn't been tuned
since it was built
in, like, 1898.
And we tried to tune up
to it at the beginning.
And actually on the album you
can hear, I'm hitting this note
and the horns is trying
to squeeze their--
breathe their mouthpieces and
do all this, and try and get it.
So when everybody else
was playing in A flat,
I had to play in A natural.
Because any time we played,
I had to play a half step up
because the piano was so flat.
So it would kind of even out as
good as-- or as best we could.
But that was just
something you had to do.
It wasn't like you
could talk about it,
or say, OK, we got a
tuning adjuster thing
like they have on
electric pianos now.
No, we just did it.
CHARLIE SAWYER: You
folks are very quiet.
Do you have questions?
RON LEVY: You've got some
more good questions here.
You said, how did you manage
to live a life living that way
day after day, year after year?
It was like being in the army.
And we even had
uniforms, band uniforms.
But it was-- every single
person except for Sonny Freeman
at least got married and
divorced at least once.
Everybody that came
into the band married
was divorced, sometimes two or
three times with different--
the longer I stayed in
the band, and if somebody
was in the band for a
long time, that happened.
Very high divorce rate.
Who paid your traveling
expenses, your plane tickets,
hotels, food?
The organization always
paid for the plane tickets.
In the very beginning we had
to pay our own hotel bills.
And we would always stay
at some real crappy hotel,
and we would double
and triple up.
And that changed after
about a, year or two.
And food, we had to
buy our own food.
And it wasn't until,
like the last year
that we got-- in
1976, we got $25 a day
per diem, which was--
you get a lot for $25.
Salary.
How much did the band
members make in those days?
It depended on seniority.
CHARLIE SAWYER: How was
it compared to, say,
what Ray Charles--
RON LEVY: Nobody knew
what anybody else made.
You weren't allowed
to talk about that,
to say-- even your close
friends in the band,
you couldn't say,
come on, tell me.
I won't say a word.
You couldn't do that.
That was one of the rules
that you couldn't do.
But when I first
started, it was 1969.
I was making $250 a week.
And by 1976, I was
making $750 a week.
But-- and the next question is--
were your taxes and FICA always
withheld?
Yes, they were always
withheld, but the people that
withheld them always
didn't pay them.
So for the last year
and a half, two years,
that I was with the band,
I lived in New York City
at the time, so my
city tax, my state tax
and federal tax and FICA
were withdrawn from my pay.
And it wasn't paid out.
It wasn't paid for
the proper places.
And I'm not going
to say who took it
because I don't actually know.
But it was somebody
who had access to it.
And the thing was, by the end
of the last, I'd say year,
that all came out.
And everybody in the
band got a tax audit.
So what happened was, every
Sunday night, Sunday night
was pay night.
And there was always
an IRS guy there, too.
So we had to pay all of
our withholding taxes
for that week, plus the
corresponding week for the year
before.
So in other words, probably
like 70% of was our pay
was taken out.
So even though I was making
$750, I was only making $200.
I was only keeping
$200 cash, and that
was impossible to keep
an apartment in New York
and my parking for my
car and living expenses
and this and that, and all that.
And that's why I left.
That's one of the reasons why.
CHARLIE SAWYER: We're kind
of running short on time.
So I want to skip to three
questions about B.B. King.
What is your appraisal
of B.B. King, the person?
RON LEVY: Completely
honorable, class person
who raised the standards of
professionalism for everybody
that he came in contact with in.
This last episode
that I was talking
about with the
money getting funny,
all those people were fired as
soon as he found out about it.
And he tried to help us,
but he was in a bind.
He was in the same bind we were.
But B.B. is very shrewd and
very kind-hearted person.
I would say he's probably one
of the most beloved artists
that I've ever
seen, by everybody.
And as you saw in that
little clip that we did,
in the seven years that I worked
with him and all the years
since, and the times I
knew him from before,
I never saw him
pause or even take
like a 10-second or 20-second,
30-second break in the show.
You know how sometimes you see
a musician and their playing,
and then they're kind of
phoning it in for a chorus.
I never saw him do that, ever.
All those faces that
you see him make
and all that intensity
was 100% sincere and real.
And being next to that every
night and playing next to him
was an unbelievably educational
experience on many levels.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Your appraisal
of B.B. King, the musician.
RON LEVY: The musician.
Well, that ties
in with all that.
Look, he's one of the
most influential musicians
of the century, of
this past century.
I've said this before,
that there'd only
be maybe four or five guitar
players in the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame if they didn't
make it doing one of B.B. King's
riffs.
If they didn't play
one of B.B. King's
riffs to get over and
be famous, there'd
be maybe four, five, six guys in
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
Maybe Chuck Berry, Bo
Diddley, something like that.
But Clapton, he
wouldn't be in it.
Hendrix, he wouldn't be in it.
You know, all those
guys like that.
Any of the English guys,
they wouldn't be in it.
Anybody you can
think of pretty much
wouldn't be in it if
they were excluded
from copying Albert King or B.B.
King, getting recognized off
of that.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Yes.
J. Geils' answer to
the same question,
he said, in this category of
American improvisational music,
you have a handful
of giants starting
with Louis Armstrong, Duke
Ellington, Charlie Parker,
Miles Davis, and B.B. King.
And he puts him in that--
RON LEVY: Yeah.
CHARLIE SAWYER: And
my last question.
What is B.B.'s legacy?
RON LEVY: I think
his legacy will
be that he's one of the most
beloved and honest and sincere
artists that ever graced
the stage of any generation.
I've never seen a more
sincere, honest artist.
When you saw that clip
before, in Africa,
I mean, here's B.B. Playing
in Kinshasa, Africa,
in front of 90,000 Zairians.
The leader of that
country-- granted,
he was a brutal dictator--
but he was still,
you know, it's not an
English colony anymore.
And the intensity and
how he presents himself,
when you look at that
video, he's not jiving.
It's not an act.
It's real.
So if anything you're going
to say about B.B. King is he's
real.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Yes.
I'll agree and affirm
everything you said
and add one thing in my opinion.
100 years from now,
if people still
listen to blues music, more
than any other one thing,
it will be B.B. King
who made that possible.
B.B.'s popularity, his
spreading of this music,
is what gives the
possibility this
will not be a kind of
little passing episode,
oh, the blues, you know,
in the 20th century
there was a kind of
romance with the blues,
and then it's a
footnote in history.
I think that won't happen
because of B.B. King.
RON LEVY: He was
the total package.
I mean, unbelievable singer,
innovative guitar player
that everybody copies.
Like I said, there's 100 guys
in the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame that copied him that
are in there because of him,
CHARLIE SAWYER: He's almost
89 and he's still on the road.
He's still out there playing.
He played at--
RON LEVY: The stage is his home.
CHARLIE SAWYER: Yes.
Then you must come back.
RON LEVY: Thank you.
I'd love to.
CHARLIE SAWYER: We'll come
back and next time we'll
make some music together.